[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
de rosa pérez más de burros a bienvenida
buena mañana de jueves vamos a abrir
esta revista de prensa como lo que
estábamos avanzando el polémico
reportaje publicado en la revista de
moda vogue titulado retrato de la
valentía de la primera dama de ucrania
elena silencia el texto es de rachel
dona dio y de fotografías de la
reconocida fotógrafa annie leibovitz
buenos días raúl exactamente y antes de
entrar en detalle en este texto vamos a
comentar la polémica que mencionabas que
ha generado este reportaje porque es de
estos artículos a que a su vez
desencadena en decenas de titulares en
otros medios de comunicación vamos a ver
la cuestión es que tanto a elena se leen
scala primera dama esposa de volodymyr
selenski tanto como al presidente
ucraniano como tal ya les habían hecho
previamente
decenas de perfiles y de reportajes y de
sesiones de fotos de hecho la propia
primera dama ya protagonizó un perfil en
book en abril sin embargo lo que ha
llamado especialmente la atención
lo que ha sido muy comentado es esta
sesión de fotografías a cargo como bien
decías de la reconocida annie leibovitz
como vemos aquí aquí detrás no son
fotografías que están puestas en escena
en lo que por otro lado es digamos el
adecor la escenografía real de estos
momentos de ucrania y donde vive de
hecho esta pareja no pero por ejemplo
esta fotografía en el aeropuerto de jos
tomen con las mujeres soldados al lado
el que fue uno de los primeros puntos de
ataque del ejército ruso recordemos al
principio de esta invasión pues ha
generado una cierta polémica más bien
desde el punto de vista moral no como
está el país en guerra está muriendo
gente no es momento de posar para vos
pero bien nadie tanto en la medios de
comunicación internacionales como
ucranianos vemos que hay muchos
ucranianos que apoyan a la primera dama
en esta voluntad digamos de proyectar
una imagen de coraje y de resistencia al
resto del mundo porque de hecho raúl
este ha sido una de las actividades
centrales tanto del propio presidente es
el ens que como de ella desde que empezó
esta guerra a nadie vidas de lenski como
un gran estratega de las relaciones
internacionales sino como alguien que ha
buscado sobre todo el apoyo
internacional tanto de los políticos de
los gobiernos y los parlamentos como de
la sociedad civil no desde que empezó
esta guerra esta invasión de ucraniano
en términos de apoyo de la opinión
pública o de armamento etcétera rosa y
es que en imagen que proyecta hablen así
les cases entre mucho ese texto no lo
que estamos hablando previamente
efectivamente vamos a centrarnos mucho
en esto porque es un poco la cuestión
central a analizar en este reportaje
bien te leo si te parece un poco para un
párrafo introductorio de lo que es esta
pieza dice la esposa del presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski guionista
de comedia desde hace mucho tiempo ella
recordemos trabajaba consell en que la
productora donde él era actor ella
siendo guionista siempre prefirió
quedarse detrás de escena mientras que
su esposo un cómico convertido en
político cuya presidencia aún puede
determinar el destino del mundo libre
en el centro de atención pero desde que
rusia invadió ucrania el 24 de febrero
de lenz k se encontró en el centro de
una tragedia y precisamente señala cómo
se ha convertido en el rostro de la
sociedad civil de una nación de mujeres
madres de hecho el propio de lenski
preguntado también en este reportaje
admira el coraje de su mujer y dice que
es un ejemplo para las mujeres y los
niños que han decidido quedarse en el
país dice el texto si se leen es que
lidera una nación de civiles que de la
noche a la mañana se han convertido en
combatientes ella ha cargado con el peso
emocional siempre este rol de primera
dama muy cargado de estereotipos de
género pero según la estilista de esta
sesión julie peli pas una ucraniana con
la residencia en londres ella se lens k
intenta romper un poco con estos
estereotipos no dice que su imagen
muestra que ucrania ya no es un país de
oligarcas y cleptócratas de los años
post soviéticos y dice cuando se leen es
que viste un traje pantalón no teme
parecer demasiado masculina al lado del
presidente una señal de una mujer
moderna en ucrania no tenemos miedo de
demostrar que somos más fuertes que
somos iguales a los hombres y algo a
destacar de este reportaje y es que no
se da tanta importancia a la ropa que
visten las personas fotografiadas como
en otros reportajes de la revista vogue
de hecho sólo se menciona al final en
esta fotografía en el pie de esta
fotografía que la primera dama viste
diseñadores ucranianos además fue como
como lo decías a rosa o lenny y
volodymir trabajaron juntos haciendo
ficción efectivamente y de hecho tal y
como señala este texto cuando se lentes
que entré a la presidencia trabajo a
muchos colegas ya muchos amigos de la
televisión a la administración a lo que
le ha generado bastantes problemas pero
también a campañas de comunicación
brillantes no bueno para entrar en
rápidamente cómo se conocieron tal y
como explica este reportaje ambos
crecieron en la misma ciudad del sureste
de ucrania una ciudad de habla
mayoritariamente rusa como era el caso
en sus hogares se conocieron en la
secundaria y luego durante de hecho los
últimos años de la unión soviética
precisamente la primera dama dice somos
otra generación cuando alguien comienza
a decirnos que no hay ucranianos y que
uno ya no es sólo un mal ruso no lo
compramos en la universidad ella estudió
arquitectura y el derecho pero ambos
luego se dedicaron a la comedia y para
terminar pues excelentes que dice que
obviamente espera que acabe la guerra lo
antes posible de hecho ella no quería
que su marido se postulará a la
presidencia dice que después de lucha
entendió que era una guerra destinada a
exterminar nos a todos una guerra de
exterminio pero que está convencida que
ucrania va a vencer y de aquí este
titular no en la coraje de la primera
dama de ucrania pues muchísimas gracias
rosa por esta revista de prensa el día
de hoy el jueves mañana con más pasamos
a saludar de nuestro segundo invitado